هناك في كهرمان مرعش مسقط راس زلزال تركيا
الذي حصد ارواح حشرات الالاف من البشر
كانا هناك وعلى مدار اكثر من اسبوع
مراسلنا غسان ابو لوز والمصور باسل العلي
تجربه غامره بالمشاعر حيث تم نقل الصوره
والارقام ومتابعه عمليات الانقاذ هناك
في وقت كانت المخاوف حقيقيه من انهيار
المباني المتضرره مع تاثير الهزات
الارتداديه المستمره هذا بخلاف الظروف
الجويه القاسيه متعلقات المفقودين
المتناظره بين الخطام دعاء الاهالي على
امل لقاء جديد وانين العالقين تحت الانقاض
رهبه المشهد وهواء برائحه الموت
يعبر غسان عن تجربته قائلا
تتثائب الارض فينام الناس نومتهم الاخيره
التثائب اصبح شؤما والنوم وداعا اليوم
نستضيف الثنائي لمشاركه تجربتهم
[موسيقى]
نورنا في الاستوديو باسل العلي اهلا بك يا
باسل صورنا ومن اعمال ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه غسان ابو اللوز يسعد صباحك يا
غسان بك معانا غسان اول نبدا
بمشاهداتك العينيه وكيف كانت تجربتك في
تغطيتك لزلزال
صيام صباح الخير صباح الخير نادين تجربه
مؤلمه وقاسيه جدا تجربه يعني مختلطه
بالحزن والالم والاسى وكل شيء يعني ممكن
ان يشعر به الانسان تجربه ايضا يعني كان
فيها بصيص من الامل كنا يعني نفرح عندما
نسمع بانقاذ اشخاص على قيد الحياه كنا
نعيش هذه اللحظات وكنا ننتظر مع الاهالي
وننتظر مع المنقذين ساعات طويله يعني كنا
نتمنى دائما ان يكون هناك المزيد من
الاشخاص على قيد الحياه يعني وضع انساني
كان صعب جدا دمار في كل مكان كنا يعني
دائما نتساءل شو وضع الناس تحت هذه
الانقاض تحت ملايين الاطنان من الركام
والحطام كيف كانوا يعيشوا ما زالوا على
قيد الحياه اللي مات كيف وضعه وكيف ظرفه
يعني كيف
الطوابق في المباني يعني
متراصه بهذا الشكل يعني كنا دائما في حاله
من الذهول
وكنا في دائما في حاله من
التساؤل الدائم خصوصا الاهالي او من خرج
من تحت الانقاذ يعني نحاول نسمع لهم قصصهم
يعني كانت فعلا ماساه يعني
يعني كثير من الاحيان كنت اعجز عن سهام
وغسان نحن نحيي صمودك وهدوءك اثناء
التغطيه وانت دائما ملك في الميدان ولدينا
ايضا ملوك في الميدان مصورين زميلنا باسل
العلي باسل اليوم في هذه التغطيه كانت
الناس بدها تشوف قدر الامكان يعني من خلال
فيديوهات مشاهد اكثر من انه تغطيات اخرى
لنسمع جديد التصريحات السياسيه والتصريحات
الصحفيه اليوم كمصور ومصور لمشاهد كل
الناس اعينها عليها شو كانت اكثر ما يلفظك
بالاول
نادين بدايه يعني اللي شفتوه كله على
الشاشه هو ما بيجي واحد من بالميه من
المشاهد الحقيقيه يعني هو كان بالاول
وبالاخر في عندي رساله بدي اوصلها بالصوره
وكانت مشاهد صعبه يعني مشاهد قاسيه جدا
دمار ذكريات الناس صورهم مجوهراتهم لما
تشوفيهم على الارض تصير تتخيلي هل هم فعلا
مجرد ارقام ولا هم بشر ولا هم حجم الدمار
كان هائل جدا يعني
وصعب يعني الجثث
الاشلاء مع العلم يعني غطيت حروب كثير بس
ما اثرت في بقدر
الكارثه هاي يعني كانت تاثيرها فعلا صعب
جدا يعني
انت كنت مع باسل وكنتم مشاهدين على اكثر
من لحظه تم فيها استخراج ضحايا واستخراج
كمال احياء من تحت الانقاض خصوصا الاطفال
شو اكثر لحظه اثرت على غسان
كل المشاهد مؤثره سهام كل ما شاهدناه مؤثر
لكن اكثر يعني حاله كنا مرتبطين فيها لا
ادري لماذا بالذات هذه الحاله وهي حاله
الطفله عائشه تبعناها لاكثر من اربع ساعات
وزميل باسل كان يعني هو البطل والجندي
المجهول لنقل هذه الصوره ويعني الجهد
الاكبر كان يقع على باسل نقل هذه الصوره
للعالم كله وتفاجئنا بحجم كبير من الناس
اللي كانوا يعني متابعين
ومتعاطفين مع هذه الطفله عائشه تحديدا
فكانت هذه القصه يعني اكثر قصه اثرت في
خصوصا انه في هذيك الليله فجر هذا اليوم
كان ابني بعث لي فويس نوت يعني بيجهش
بالبكاء وبيقول لي انا خايف عليك ومتى بدك
تروح وكذا بعد ساعات اجت الثلاث طفلات
هذول اللي تبعناهم ما فيهم عائشه اللي
ظلينا لاخر لحظه حتى اخرجوها على قيد
الحياه والحمد لله
كانت يعني مشاعر مختلطه حتى بعد ما انهينا
اللايف بعد اربع ساعات اكثر من اربع ساعات
فجاءت بباسل انه نهار من البكاء انهار
بشكل يعني كبير جدا يعني بجوز استمر لمده
ساعه وهو يبكي وانا نحاول نهدي عليه يعني
الوضع كان صعب جدا نعم بالفعل المعلومه
يعني احنا تفاجانا
يعني هاي الازمات الانسانيه اللي بتلاحق
الشخص وخصوصا انتم كنتم في قلب الحدث
لباسا لحظه البكاء شو اللي صار يعني
وخصوصا انت عم بتصور هل في ضوابط معينه
انه بتقول لا لازم اوقف خصوصا انه في ممكن
قتلى او نجيب مثلا ممكن لو كانت هي لو
كانوا معطينا اشاره انه هي ميته ممكن اني
ما كنت اصور بس لانه قلنا على ثقه انه راح
يطلعوها عايشه يعني
لحظه انا يعني انا كان كل تركيزي بالبدايه
بالصوره مركز
بعد ما خلصنا نقل الهواء يعني ضلينا احنا
اربع ساعات ونص تقريبا
رجعت يعني كنت مركز بس بصورتي رجعت صورتها
ظلت في خيالي وهي عم بتاشر يعني انه عايشه
يعني طلعت انه صوره وكلمات غسان اثرت انه
عائشه عائشه عائشه خرجت من رحم الموت
فكانت فعلا يعني هي لحظتها يعني لاول مره
بصراحه بنهار مثل هيك طيب غسان انتم يعني
ما غطيتوا بس اللحظات الزلزال ولكن عشتو
مع الناس عشتو مع الاهالي مخاوفهم ولحظات
محاوله استيعابهم للصدمه كيف كان شعوركم
انتم بين الناس وعايشين معاهم في الزلزال
[موسيقى]
شعور صعب جدا الواحد يفقد بيته سهام شعور
يعني كارثه تخيلي سهام البيت فكره البيت
قائمه على الحب والاستقرار والعاطفه
والحنان والملاذ الاخير يعني كل هذه
الافكار اللي الانسان بشعر فيها بالراحه
وهو بيته الواحد فتخيل هذا البيت يتحول
الى وحش ممكن ان يبتلعك في اي لحظه
وبالتالي كان صعب جدا هذا الشعور انه
الناس صارت تخاف من البيت الناس صارت تخاف
من اي سقف تدخل اي سقف الناس بالسيارات
كنا نشاهدهم حتى المرافق اللي كان موجود
معنا بنوجه له تحيه اسمه نذير ادريس رفض
يعني احنا استطعنا بعد جهد جهيد نعثر على
فندق يعني كم ليله بالفندق رفض رفض قاطع
انه يدخل معنا بالفندق ويشاركنا بالفندق
يعني كان عنده دائما مقوله يقول انا عندي
بنات انا عندي بنات فيضطر ينام بالسياره
بدرجه حراره متدنيه جدا عشره تحت صفر ولا
يدخل فكانت الفكره يعني انه الواحد البيت
يتحول بهذه الطريقه الى هذا الوحش الى هذا
الكذا هذه المعاناه يعني حتى الناس اللي
ممكن يرجعوا على بيوتهم ضلوا خايفين فكانت
المعاناه كبيره جدا رحنا صورنا عند عائله
سوريه غسان زوجه والبنات بخيمه والاب
بالبيت
انت وباسل بين كل التخطيات اللي غطيتوها
لقناه العربيه هل كانت هذه الاصعب
نعم بالفعل الاصعب نادين لما يكون الانسان
على ارضيه مش ثابته فهو دائما في خطر
الحرب هناك جبهه معروفه ان هناك جبهه ممكن
يسقط صاروخ على بنايه على بنايتين لكن انت
بتحكي عن ارض كلها بتهتز طيب باسل كان كان
يشوفني دائما اني انا دايما قلقان لانه
فعلا انا يعني كنت اخاف ادخل لانه الارض
دائما بتهتز دائما يعني صابني حاله من
الفوبيا ومن الخوف من القلق
[موسيقى]
الاصعب والاقصى
الله يعافيكم شكرا لكم